Squeezie va-t-il arrêter Youtube je lui
pose la question j'arrête Youtube je
prends ma retraite tu penses qu'un jour
il y aura une vidéo de ce type là ouais
je pense je pense qu'on est très bon on
est tous très bon dans quelque chose
pendant un un temps donné mais tout es
dans le un temps donné je pense qu'au
bout d'un moment on en parlait tout à
l'heure tu as peut-être un peu plus
envie de te concentrer sur le perso sur
tes enfants sur ta famille sur autre
chose que le travail en tout cas je me
le souhaite je me souhaite un jour
d'être moins branché travail et de vivre
un peu plus la vie comme tu es sensé la
vivre globalement quoi et vivent des des
choses dans le perso tout le monde fait
son temps dans ce qu'il fait et c'est
pas une mauvaise chose et puis il y aura
des les nouveaux qui vont arriver qui
seront trois fois plus forts je les
regarderai je ferai ah qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont fort les bâards et ce sera cool